joining me now is the legal commentator
joshua rosenberg uh good evening joshua
thanks for being with us so
10 a.m tomorrow old bailey history will
be made tell us
um what's going to happen and the
background to this well what's going to
happen tomorrow is that a young man
called ben oliver who's 25 is going to
be sentenced for the manslaughter of his
74 year old grandfather david oliver
last year terrible case the
defendant was cleared of murder by a
jury but admitted manslaughter due to
diminished responsibility so quite an
interesting challenge for the judge
judge monroe will hear
arguments um from the prosecution and
the defense which you won't be able to
broadcast tomorrow morning because all
you'll see is the judge uh delivering
her reasons for sentencing uh this young
man assuming that she agrees to allow
the proceedings to be televised which
we're all assuming she will and what she
will do
is she will explain a little bit of the
background to the crime
she will explain the arguments that were
put on behalf of this defendant ben
oliver she will explain how sentencing
works how guidelines apply
mitigating and aggravating factors and
then she will tell ben oliver what the
sentence is that he must serve for
manslaughter
and when she finishes doing that that
will be the end of the broadcast uh and
that is all you we will see we won't see
the defendant we won't see the lawyers
we won't see the victim's family we
won't see anybody but the judge right so
it's limited to these sentencing remarks
by the judge why not um
more of the trial if the public can go
into court
for a trial why not the the cameras
covering all of it
i think the judges have been very
concerned about this arrangement i mean
you're looking at pictures of the old
bailey and all you'll see tomorrow
is the judge
there is concern that there might be a
reaction in court by the family there
might be a disturbance in court uh it
might be uh difficult for uh the family
the victims uh even for the lawyers to
begin with uh to have these very
sensitive issues uh broadcast now it's
perfectly true that appeals in england
and wales are broadcast already and the
lawyers have got very used to that but
you don't usually see witnesses in those
cases
and
all you hear from other lawyers
and the judge and so i suppose this is
being done gradually but i i think it's
fair to say the broadcasters hope that
if this is a success it will be extended
to a greater part of the trial
proceedings yeah because of course some
countries i suppose most famously the us
do
go much further don't they
they do and
some of us remember the trial of a man
called oj simpson which was seen as a
bit of a media circus because that was
broadcast live and uh it was thought
that everybody the police the lawyers
even the judge were playing to the
cameras uh and people are very concerned
that we shouldn't see anything like that
in england and wales it's fair to say
that criminal trials in scotland can be
broadcast because the restrictions
passed on cameras in court obviously
these were still cameras in those days
passed in the 1920s almost 100 years ago
were never applied in scotland but in
scotland you need the consent of
everybody concerned the distinctive
thing about what's happening in england
and wales is you won't need the consent
of the defendant for the case to be uh
broadcast you won't need the consent of
anybody but the judge who can of course
in his or her discretion decide that
this is not a case that's suitable for
broadcast right and i'm interested you
said
um or i think you said a little bit
earlier that you thought one day more of
the trial may be broadcast
i suppose that depends on how this
stage of of uh this goes
very much so
what those behind the broadcasting and
this includes the judges and the
ministry of justice uh think
is that if we see judges doing their job
on camera
we will respect the very difficult task
a judge has in passing sentence in
assessing the guidelines in assessing
how this case case fits within the
guidelines whether you reduce the
sentence for some reason whether you
increase it for some reason or whatever
we can of course
see
these remarks by going to court nobody
has the time to do that but they're also
often published in writing but people
don't take the trouble to read them i
think when people do understand what
sentencing involves i think they will
respect the judges obviously
families
in a murder case manslaughter case or
any case where somebody's been injured
often say that the sentence is too low
and it can be increased by the court of
appeal but the thinking is the more we
see how seriously the courts take this
sentencing exercise the more respect the
public will have for it right and just
20 seconds left it'd be on a time delay
though will it there'll be some sort of
uh delay building a small a small time
delay pretty much as live only about a
minute's delay um but the judge will
have a big red button and so will the
broadcasters if anything happens if
there's an interruption for example then
the the feed will be cut and the
broadcast will be ended okay uh joshua
good to have you on thank you very much
for explaining what is going to happen
tomorrow thanks very much